new york times bestselling author
ta-nehisi coates is sharing his personal
journey with
younger readers his new book the
beautiful struggle was adapted from his
2008 memoir of the same name to appeal
to young adults it's about growing up in
west baltimore
in the 1980s coates writes about how he
succeeded and became the man he is with
the help of his parents
tough love hussey coats joins us now
good morning thank you so much for being
here
thanks for having me what kind of a
challenge is it to take something that
you wrote is the first book you wrote i
think 12 what are we 12
13 years ago now and and 12 years going
on with 13.
can you believe it
tom flies time flies man yeah sure thing
but
so so how did you what was your approach
in adapting this for for younger readers
well i i actually i had quite a bit of
help adapting it but i i think um
one of the the the really fortunate
things about it
when i wrote it at the time i think i
was 31 when beautiful struggle published
and and
what i what i always imagined was that
it was a younger version of me say in my
early 20s
writing to a high school slash middle
school version of me
yeah so it was always supposed to be the
book that i would have wanted to see
at that period of time so in many ways i
think that the foundation was there
yeah that's that's such an interesting
state of mind to put you i think so too
but tahasi when i look at your life
you've had really quite a life and i
wonder if you were hard on yourself
because you describe yourself going to
school as a monument to unknowledge
fat cheeks that you talked a lot in
second grade they actually diagnosed you
as
probably mentally challenged would be a
very polite way of saying
wow but your mom always believed she
your mom always believed she never gave
up on you but
and i look at you do you ever marvel
about how your life turned out when you
consider the background
of how you started i i'm saying kudos
and bravo to your mom
i do i do you know i i had a you know a
great mother i mean my mom taught me to
read she's probably the most
consequential figure in terms of me me
being a writer in the first place
um but you know you know what i i have
to say gail i think
like if i had to completely write that
book
again now i would have been much more
understanding of the younger me um
it's telling that it was published that
you know uh you know originally almost
12 years ago because you know i've now
had some experience some time my own son
is now 20 years old
you know what i mean i i know you know
what what kids are actually like
and i think a lot in that book is me
trying to figure out what's wrong with
me
and if i could say anything to my
younger self now i would say nothing
nothing at all nothing at all
you write about you write about how your
mom was always looking towards mecca
which is
howard city which i i love that idea
and and she said what i could what you
write is i what i could not understand
was that she believed that i was owed
that no matter what i done in high
school
somehow i was entitled to see the mecca
to find my place in this great
black cosmo cosmopolis where does
as you look back now what was the root
of that faith
in that she had do you think so i think
first of all my mom you know herself she
you know i
was a graduate of hbcu cop in you know
in
in in baltimore and i think um having
that reference point a lot of you know
her you know sisters and relatives who'd
gone
had gone to you know hbcus university of
maryland uh eastern shore and so that
was
you know i think that sense in general
of hbcus
as a kind of you know place of of haven
you know for for black kids but i think
more than that and this goes back to
you know what i was saying before i
think at that time my mom
really had that kind of forgiveness and
tenderness that i wish i had had when i
when i when i wrote the book
um she probably had you know some great
understanding herself having been a
teacher
that you know wait where you start is
not who you
where you end up and 16 year old you is
not a verdict
on who you ultimately will be we're
looking we just saw a shot of you when
you were at howard but i really i got
such a kick out of your mom because
she you wrote that she said you wanted
to you didn't want to go to howard at
first
and your mom gave you that i didn't your
mom gave you that you know what this is
smile when she was talking about what's
going to happen here
that when you met when you made a
mistake she made you do an essay to
write over and over what you did and how
you did it and why you did it
but i want to talk to you tom ozzy about
the current events because
all of us are still reeling and so
rocked by what happened at the capitol
on january 6 well i'll remember we will
never
ever forget what went through your mind
when you saw that unfold at the united
states capital
uh
this is horrible to say we told you so
i wouldn't even say i told you so we
told you so who's it i think there have
been a number of
the we as i would say african-american
writers and you know african-americans
at large i think there were a number of
people
um that in the wake of donald trump's
election
uh were very very clear about the great
danger
uh that you know a a trump presidency
would pose
uh to not just to black people but to
the united states itself and
we you know we're told that you know
we're making too much out of this
you know oh he's not really a white
supremacist oh it's not that bad oh the
office of the presidency
will sober him oh there people around
him who will make sure
you know and curb his power and
his presidency ends with him inciting an
attack
on the congress of the united states of
america
hopefully people will take this
seriously now what do you think
how how significant do you think the
damage is from this
oh i think it's quite significant i
think it's quite significant because
if i i i don't have the exact numbers
but i believe ultimately even after that
attack
um at least half perhaps a majority
of the republican congress people in the
house of representatives
against you know uh the idea of
affirming the vote
people still supported him yes still
supported and so and so you you have to
say that there is
you know um the riot can almost be a
distraction the insurrection can be a
distraction
there is a deeply felt sense in a
certain
population in this country that we
should have a minoritarian form of
government
you know um and that that's not going
away okay i apologize we have to go
i so appreciate you being here the
beautiful struggle is the book thomas
coates thank you so much
for joining us we'll be right back good
to see you